[Music]  on july 8 1996 the world was introduced  to the spice girls  [Music]  baby scary and  sporty very much  [Music]  three studio albums 11 singles 90  million records sold and a whole lot of  girl power  quickly achieving world domination the  spice girls hold the title of  best-selling girl group of all time  [Music]  showing off their acting chops the girls  were a box office success with the  release of their film spice world  grossing over 100 million worldwide  and with 25 years of spice it is no  surprise the ladies have become icons  influencing some of today's biggest  stars including emma stone lily collins  and of course adele  [Music]  you